challenges
ranging from an unprecedented deadly
pandemic
to an unprecedented attack on our
democracy
thank you for your service
for your sacrifice and for your
dedication i am honored to serve
alongside you
and second as we begin a new year
and as we prepare to mark a solemn
anniversary tomorrow
it is a fitting time to reaffirm
that we at the department of justice
will do everything in our power
to defend the american people
and american democracy
we will defend our democratic
institutions from attack
we will protect those who serve the
public from violence and threats of
violence
we will protect the cornerstone of our
democracy
the right to every eligible citizen
to cast a vote that counts and we will
do all of this in a manner that adheres
to the rule of law
and honors our obligation to protect the
civil rights and civil liberties of
everyone
in this country
will mark the first anniversary of
january 6 2021.
the day the united states capital was
attacked while lawmakers met to affirm
the results of a presidential election
in the early afternoon of january 6
as united states senate and house of
representatives were meeting to certify
the vote count of the electoral college
a large crowd gathered outside the
capitol building
shortly after 2pm pm
individuals in the crowd began to force
entry into the capital
by smashing windows and assaulting u.s
capitol police
who were stationed there to protect the
members of congress as they took part
in one of the most solemn proceedings of
our democracy
others in the crowd encouraged and
assisted
those who attacked the police
over the course of several hours
outnumbered law enforcement officers
sustained a barrage of repeated violent
attacks
about 80 capitol police and 60 d.c
metropolitan police were assaulted
as our own court filings and thousands
of public videos of the event to test
perpetrators punched dozens of law
enforcement officers
knocking some officers unconscious
some perpetrators tackled and dragged
law enforcement officers among the many
examples of such violence
one officer was crushed in a door
another was dragged down a set of stairs
face down
repeatedly tased and beaten and suffered
a heart attack
some perpetrators attacked law
enforcement officers with chemical
agents that burned their eyes and skin
and some assaulted officers with pipes
poles and other dangerous or deadly
weapons
perpetrators also targeted assaulted
tackled and harassed journalists and
destroyed their equipment
with increasing numbers of individuals
having breached the capital
members of the senate and the house of
representatives
including the president of the senate
vice president mike pence
had to be evacuated
as a consequence proceedings in both
chambers were disrupted for hours
interfering with a fundamental element
of american democracy
the peaceful transfer of power
from one administration to the next
those involved must be held accountable
and there is no higher priority for us
at the department of justice
it is impossible to overstate the
heroism of the capitol police officers
washington d.c metropolitan police
department officers
and other law enforcement officers who
defended and secured the capitol that
day
they demonstrated to all of us
and to our country what true courage
looks like
their resolve
their sacrifice
and their bravery
protected thousands of people working
inside the capitol that day
five officers who responded selflessly
to the attack on january 6
have since lost their lives
i ask everyone to please join me in a
moment of silence
in recognition of the service and
sacrifice of officer brian siknik
officer howard liebengood
officer jeffrey smith
officer gunther hashida
and officer kyle defry tag
i know i speak for all of us in saying
that tomorrow
and in our work in the days ahead
we will not only remember them
we will do everything we can
to honor
them the aftermath of the attack the
justice department began its work on
what has become one of the largest most
complex and most resource intensive
investigations in our history
only a small number of perpetrators were
arrested in the tumult of january 6
itself
every day since
we have worked to identify investigate
and hamper and apprehend defendants from
across the country
and we have done so at record speed and
scale
in the midst of a pandemic during which
some grand juries and courtrooms were
not able to operate
led by the u.s attorney's office for the
district of columbia
and the fbi's washington field office
doj personnel across the department
in nearly all 56 field offices in nearly
all 94 united states attorney's offices
and in many main justice components
have worked countless hours to
investigate the attack
approximately 70 prosecutors from the
district of columbia and another 70 from
other u.s attorney's offices and doj
divisions have participated in this
investigation
so far
we have issued over five thousand
subpoenas and search warrants
seized approximately two thousand
devices
poured through over twenty 000 hours of
video footage
and searched through an estimated 15
terabytes of data
we have received over 300 000 tips from
ordinary citizens
who have been our indispensable partners
in this effort
the abs the fbi's website continues to
post photos of persons in connection
with the events of january 6th
and we continue to seek the public's
assistance
in identifying those individuals
as of today we have arrested and charged
more than
725 defendants
in nearly all 50 states and the district
of columbia
for their roles in the january 6th
attack
in charging the perpetrators we have
followed well-worn prosecutorial
practices
those who assaulted officers or damaged
the capitol face greater charges
those who conspired with others to
obstruct the vote count
also face greater charges
those who did not undertake such conduct
have been charged with lesser offenses
particularly if they accepted their
responsibility early and cooperated with
the investigation
in the first months of the investigation
approximately 145 defendants pled guilty
to misdemeanors
mostly defendants who did not cause
injury or damage
such pleas reflect the facts of those
cases and the defendant's acceptance of
responsibility
and they help conserve both judicial and
prosecutorial resources
so that attention can properly focus on
the more serious perpetrators
in complex cases initial charges are
often less severe than later charge
defenses
this is purposeful as investigators
methodically collect and sift through
more evidence
by now though we have charged over
325 defendants with felonies
many for assaulting officers and many
for corruptly obstructing or attempting
to obstruct an official proceeding
20 defendants charged with felonies have
already pled guilty
approximately 40 defendants have been
charged with conspiracy to obstruct a
congressional proceeding and or to
obstruct law enforcement
in the months ahead
17 defendants are already scheduled to
go to trial for their role in felony
conspiracies
a necessary consequence to the
prosecutorial approach of charging less
serious offenses first
is that courts impose shorter sentences
before they impose longer ones
in recent weeks however as judges have
sentenced the first defendants convicted
of assaults and related violent conduct
against officers
we have seen significant sentences that
reflect the seriousness of those
offenses
both in terms of the injuries they
caused and the serious risk they posed
to our democratic institutions
the actions we have taken
thus far will not be our last
the justice department remains committed
to holding all january 6 perpetrators
at any level
accountable under law whether they were
present that day
or were otherwise criminally responsible
for the assault on our democracy
we will follow the facts
wherever they lead
because january 6 was an unprecedented
attack on the seat of our democracy
we understand that there is broad public
interest in our investigation
we understand that there are questions
about how long the investigation will
take and about what exactly we are doing
our answer is
and will continue to be
the same answer we would give to with
respect to any ongoing investigation
as long as it takes
and whatever it takes for justice to be
done
consistent with the facts and the law
i understand that this may not be the
answer some are looking for
but we will and we must speak through
our work
anything else jeopardizes the viability
of our investigations
and the civil liberties of our citizens
everyone in this room and on these
screens
is familiar with the way we conduct
investigations
and particularly complex investigations
we build investigations by laying a
foundation
we resolve more straightforward cases
first because they provide the
evidentiary foundation for more complex
cases
investigating the more overt crimes
generates linkages to less overt once
overt actors and the evidence they
provide
can lead us to others who may also have
been involved
and that evidence can serve as a
foundation for further investigative
leads and techniques
in circumstances like those of january 6
a full accounting does not suddenly
materialize
to ensure that all those criminally
responsible are held accountable we must
collect the evidence
we follow the physical evidence we
follow the digital evidence we follow
the money
but most important we follow the facts
not an agenda or an assumption
the facts tell us where to go next
over 40 years ago in the wake of the
watergate scandal the justice department
concluded that the best way to ensure
the department's independence
integrity and fair application of our
laws
and therefore the best way to ensure the
health of our democracy
is to have a set of norms to govern our
work
the central norm is that in our criminal
investigations
there cannot be different rules
depending on one's political party or
affiliation
there cannot be different rules for
friends and foes
and there cannot be different rules for
the powerful
and the powerless
there is only one rule
we follow the facts and enforce the law
in a way that respects the constitution
and protects civil liberties
we conduct every investigated
investigation
guided by the same norms
and we adhere to those norms even when
and especially when
the circumstances we face are not normal
adhering to the department's
long-standing norms is essential to our
work in defending our democracy
particularly at a time when we are
confronting a rise in violence
and unlawful threats of violence in our
shared public spaces and directed at
those who serve the public
we have all seen that americans who
serve and interact with the public at
every level
many of whom make our democracy work
every day
have been unlawfully targeted with
threats of violence and actual violence
across the country
election officials and election workers
airline flight crews school personnel
journalists
local elected officials
u.s senators and representatives
and judges prosecutors and police
officers have been threatened and or
attacked
these are our fellow citizens
who administer our elections ensure our
safe travel
teach our children report the news
represent their constituents and keep
our communities safe
some have been told that their offices
would be bombed
some have been told that they would
murdered
and precisely how
that they would be hanged
that they would be beheaded
police officers who put their lives on
the line every day
to serve our communities have been
targeted with extraordinary levels of
violence
flight crews have been assaulted
journalists have been targeted
school personnel and their families have
been threatened
a member of congress was threatened in a
gruesome voicemail
that asked if she had ever seen what a
50 caliber shell
does to a human head
another member of congress an iraq war
veteran and purple heart recipient
received threats that left her terrified
for her family
and in 2020
federal judge in new jersey was targeted
by someone who had appeared before her
in court
that person compiled information about
where the judge and her family lived and
went to church
that person found the judge's home
shot and killed her son
and injured her husband
these acts and threats of violence are
not associated
with any one set of partisan or
ideological views
but they are permeating so many parts of
our national life that they risk
becoming normalized and routine
if we do not stop them
that is dangerous for people's safety
and it is deeply dangerous for our
democracy
in a democracy people vote
argue and debate
often vociferously
in order to achieve the policy outcomes
they desire
but in a democracy
people must not employ violence or
unlawful threats of violence to affect
that outcome
citizens must not be intimidated from
exercising their constitutional rights
to free expression and association
by such unlawful conduct
the justice department will continue to
investigate violence and illegal threats
of violence
disrupt that disrupt that violence
before it occurs
and hold perpetrators accountable
we have marshaled the resources of the
department to address the rising
violence and criminal threats of
violence against election workers
against flight crews against school
personnel against journalists
against members of congress and against
federal agents prosecutors and judges
in 2021 the department charged more
defendants in criminal threat cases than
in any year
in at least the last five
as we do this work
we are guided by our commitment to
protect civil liberties
including the first amendment rights of
all citizens
the department has been clear
that expressing a political belief or
ideology
no matter how vociferously is not a
crime
we do not investigate or prosecute
people because of their views
peacefully expressing a view or ideology
no matter how extreme
is protected by the first amendment
but illegally threatening to harm or
kill another person is not
there is no first amendment right to
unlawfully threaten to harm or kill
someone
as justice scalia noted in rav vs city
of saint paul
true threats of violence are outside the
first amendment
because laws that punish such threats
quote
protect individuals from the fear of
violence
from the disruption that fear and
genders and from the possibility that
the threatened violence will occur
the latter point
it's particularly
close to home for those of us
who have investigated tragedies
ranging from the oklahoma city bombing
to the january 6 attack on the capitol
the time to address threats is when they
are made
not after the tragedy has struck
as employees of the nation's largest law
enforcement
agency
each of us understands that we have an
obligation to protect our citizens from
violence and fear of violence
and we will continue to do our part
to provide that protection
but the justice department cannot do it
alone the responsibility to bring an end
to violence and threats of violence
against those who serve the public
is one that all americans share
such conduct disrupts the peace of our
public spaces
and undermines our democracy
we are all americans
we must protect each other
the obligation to keep americans and
american democracy safe is part of the
historical inheritance of this
department
as i have noted several times before a
founding purpose of the justice
department was to battle violent
extremist attacks on our democratic
institutions
in the midst of reconstruction following
the civil war
the department's first principal task
was to cure secure the civil rights
promise by the 13th 14th and 15th
amendments
this meant protecting black americans
seeking to exercise their right to vote
from acts and threats of violence by
white supremacists
the framers of the civil war amendments
recognized that access to the ballot is
a fundamental aspect of citizenship and
self-government
the voting rights act of 1965
sought to make the promise of those
amendments real
to do so it gave the justice department
valuable tools with which to protect the
right to vote
in recent years however the protection
of the voting rights act have been
drastically weakened
the supreme court's 2013 decision in the
shelby county case
effectively eliminated the pre-clearance
protections of section 5
which had been the department's most
effective tool
for protecting voting rights over the
past half century
subsequent decisions have substantially
narrowed the reach of section 2 as well
since those decisions
there has been a dramatic increase in
legislative enactments that make it
harder for millions of eligible voters
to vote and to elect representatives
of their own choosing
those enactments range from
practices and procedures that make
voting more difficult
to redistricting maps drawn to
disadvantage both minorities and
citizens of opposing political parties
to abnormal post-election audits that
put the integrity of the voting process
at risk
to changes in voting administration
meant to diminish the authority of
locally elected or nonpartisan election
administrators
some have even suggested permitting
state legislators to set aside the
choice of the voters themselves
as i noted in an address to the civil
rights division last june
many of those enactments have been
justified by unfounded claims of
material vote fraud in the 2020 election
those claims which have corroded
people's faith in the legitimacy of our
elections
have been repeatedly refuted by the law
enforcement and intelligence agencies of
both the last administration and this
one
as well as by every court
federal and state that has considered
them
the department of justice will continue
to do all it can to protect voting
rights with the enforcement powers we
have
it is essential that congress act to
give the department the powers we need
to ensure that every eligible voter can
cast a vote that counts
but as with violence and threats of
violence the justice department
even the congress
cannot alone defend the right to vote
the responsibility to preserve democracy
and to maintain faith in the legitimacy
of its essential processes
lies with every elected official
and with every american
all americans are entitled to free
fair and secure elections that ensure
they can select the representatives of
their choice
all americans
are entitled to live in a country in
which their public servants can go about
their jobs of serving the public free
from violence
and unlawful threats of violence
and all americans are entitled to live
in a country in which the transition
from one elected administration to the
next
is accomplished
peacefully
the justice department will never stop
working to defend the democracy to which
all americans are entitled
as i recognized when i spoke with you
all
last march
service in the department of justice is
more than a job
and more than an honor
it is a calling
each of us
you and i
came to work here because we are
committed to the rule of law
and to seeking equal justice under law
we came to work here because we are
committed to ensuring the civil rights
and civil liberties of our people
we came to work here because we are
committed to protecting our country
as our oath says
from all enemies
foreign and domestic
together
we will continue to show the american
people
by word and by deed
that these are the principles that
underlie our work
the challenges that we have faced and
that we will continue to face
are extraordinarily
but i am moved and humbled by the
extraordinary work you do every single
day to meet them
i look forward to seeing more of you in
person
soon
and to our continued work together
thank you all
[Applause]
oh